super bowl 55 is a week from this sunday  but you can already lay down your bets  yesterday the westgate superbook  unveiled its highly anticipated prop  bets they have over 400 bets  everything from the coin toss and mvp to  some pretty wild ones like the  buccaneers will have more touchdowns  in the first half than the golden  knights will have stanley cup wins  this season props are big money though  for the books  each and every year the percentages go  up on how much we take on the prop  propositions  versus the game itself i think we'll  probably look around  65 to 70 percent of all the bets on the  super bowl will be on these propositions  tampa bay hosts kansas city for super  bowl 55.  you can of course watch it next sunday  february 7th right here on channel 8. we  will have live coverage for you from  tampa leading up to the big game  our kevin martin will be there she will  join us live starting monday morning at  6 00 a.m it will be a lot of fun